hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back so let's just rub right
in I'm not gonna waste any time cuz I'm
gonna need as much time as possible to
get all the cuz this is gonna be our
let's go now now I just follow the path
oh good I get this one out of the way
right away maybe I could save my
flashlight when I don't need it and
hopefully that'll help me sustain my
chances for survival I don't really have
a strategy other than go get the pages
as soon as possible I should probably be
saving my sprint boy I am a fool so it
does not matter I got that one right
oh there he is hey that's gonna buddy
just uh
calm your tits there Slendy man I have a
mission to accomplish and you are not
gonna hinder that mission in any way
okay so I got a pretty good I'm gonna
try to get a pretty good lay of the land
I'm off to a good start got to right
away walk path turn off flashlight for a
bit
save my flashlight I'm pretty sure
that's a strategy that I will need to
employ and a branching path up here
let's go left first
another branching path uh-huh
I would have missed you three baller
what stray for a bit picnic haha one on
a tree where is he oh he's right back
there okay I got it I got it I got it
okay I would have missed that easily
that would have been I would have had a
son of a [ __ ] to find just on a random
tree house that even fair
alright looks like we got the normal
looking container park here no weird
roof structures I'm guessing that in
hardcore mode there are actually more
buildings and that's why it's difficult
where is it shut up Slendy where are you
there you is got it five of eight doing
good let's continue out the back way
fall the roads I think we might make it
I'm too Perot
it was another one on the beachfront but
I think that's where the tree was before
um yeah that's still closed up so let me
go up the hill and then hopefully I'll
go to the center in the building I may
because usually the building is in the
center same for on the original slender
the eight pages ah come on
can't handle fish have a page have a
page have a page yes six of eight doing
great I have a date Anna ah house don't
be guarding the outhouse [ __ ] come on
yes wha go away I don't need you
Matar my flashlight cancer for a bit
where is he oh he's right behind me
isn't he
okay I got building it's got to be in
the building not on the outside time
inside come on let's find it let's find
it find that ah
it ran behind ah laughs I got me come on
are you son of a [ __ ] where's the damn
[ __ ] get away from me
it's got to be in the building it's got
to be somewhere maybe I hate it when
it's not in the building it's gotta be
in here summer go away please please f
off and die
oh no I'm cornered I'm gonna be cornered
oh come on did you guys see the page did
you guys see it somewhere oh fudge I
can't have it in the building last
that's so stupid
ah man took a pile of bull honkey
alright let's go back up here again so
hopefully wait what oh what oh okay it's
completely turned around ah balls I was
so close seven of eight right then in
there it's just I I must have used my
sprint too much in the beginning and I
couldn't get away from him also I went
into the room which is probably big
mistake
all right whatever is there another path
out the other side of that car I don't
know huh whatever that was disappointing
that was really disappointing
I thought for sure that I would have
been able to make that I'm so upset at
myself I screwed up I knew that room was
a dead end
I knew it was and I just went in anyway
hello
outhouse in light or tower come on - ah
Jesus [ __ ] man stop being such an a-hole
Slendy where's that outhouse or porta
potty whatever you want to call it there
it is doesn't matter what you call it it
is what it is it's a place for a
portable toilet uh-huh what's that on
the ground there okay three of eight
doesn't matter get away from him
I'm actually not doing as well this time
because I don't really have a good idea
of where I am and where I've been well
here's the container park alright
alright
go straight for it where is it where
okay yeah that's fine
do your thing but show me where the
pages where's the page it's only right
here oh don't tell me it's not here ah
man it wasn't in the building was it
wasn't it all because it's not in here
it's not here
ha
balls it's not there frak alack alack
alack alright this is gonna be a pain in
the ass I should have just left the
building after it wasn't in the bathroom
the only places I've seen it in the
building is the bathroom and the other
place whenever oh it's not in the
Billboard either you're kidding me this
is gonna murder me this bull I got I
must have got really lucky to find a
page on every landmark that I was on
before right now I'm just kind of being
screwed with that's so closed over there
yeah I hear ya this is where the tree
was the random tree was before not in
this video but before before okay let's
go up this way and then we'll go back
down to the middle
oh they hear the buildings on the hill
now is it oh that's wonderful
by law it probably is in here so
see it see it no I don't see it turn
that off for a second don't want to run
out where is he
Oscar he's gonna do his own thing anyway
I don't really care anymore I didn't
check ah I didn't check this room before
he was bribed in that room
fetch first what
hang on hold up sandy hold a hold your
horses get trapped in that building you
[ __ ] where's the road follow the road
follow the road follow the road up and
then go into the middle if I look back
to where I started I will be so angry
ah that's where I started isn't that the
car that's the second thing I got frack
alack alack ax
oh hi hi I saw him moving
I saw him moving he was gliding through
the woods
oh so subtly alright go back down let's
go down this hill here where is he
oh there okay alright just keep going ah
don't get stuck on a tree I'm not seeing
many other landmarks here I've only got
five and this is not good this is not
good cuz I have no idea where I am
I don't know if I've been here before
why
ah Pass fudge oh come on he's like right
on my ass and I have no idea where I am
I'm gonna run a flashlight soon
I don't know now I'm just wandering in
the middle of the woods this is
fantastic there's never anything in this
like quarry area is there I don't think
so I don't think so oh [ __ ] I'm back
here Pass oh come on come on
shut up Slendy alright today ah
I see something did I get the one off of
this one did I did I no yes
six of eight I can still do it I'm still
in the game maybe maybe
maybe maybe not I'm gonna guess maybe
not okay I've been in the signpost here
before whoa
did he all know my flashlight oh no no
not my flashlight it's the only thing I
have in this darkness where else haven't
I been worlds over there Ben oh this
come on for life Taylor lager Oh No ah
come on
ah [ __ ] em bone [ __ ] take me I'm so
stupid I looked around the whole place
like three times looking for new
landmarks and that's such bull okay
we're in a new place now so let's just
go turn off the flashlight right in the
beginning skit to the exit and go okay
all right okay find a road road road
road road road road aha
it's this weird building whatever the
hell this is supposed to be I don't
really know I can't find a page
AHA there it is got it one all right
follow the road try to trace an outline
of the entire area first and then move
inwards cuz if you can get everything in
the outside that's like six of eight
pages OOP alright cool cool
yes yes yes yes I'm going to make it
maybe perhaps ah
three let me just calmly walk cuz I've
been using my sprint a bit too much and
it's hard to get away from him if I use
it in the beginning too much I just
follow the path nice and calmly
only sprint when he shows up
ah huh let's run let's actually get the
building here just in case there's one
in here I want to make sure I get it out
of the way so that I'm not stuck in the
building
all right come on where yet where yet
not there you gotta be in the other room
yes yes easy yes I like it
oh crap I'm gonna go out the same door
came in so I remember I don't get turned
around here okay so I came down this way
right right correct and then I was up
this hill I believe maybe I yes cuz I
hit the porta potti and then I went this
way yeah up that hill that's the one
okay I just got to go keep following the
same path if I if I get lost on the path
then that's when I'm screwed because
then I start looping in circles I miss
landmarks and stuff like that I'm headed
towards the radio tower there got this
moving along I kind of went back a bit
too far but that's okay
I think I can forgive myself come on
come on
oh yeah I came in that side that's right
hi how you [ __ ] I need to go that way
so fr yes Bob of eight come on I know I
can make this one with the path go
where'd the path go where's the path
there's no path to see out light of the
building there's got to be on the other
side of the building there's got to be a
path AHA there it is got it got it got
it got it got it I miss any other
landmarks nearby no good f off f off man
ah ah ah there we go
and then the radio tower is up on the
hill and then it was just be one more
way was at it yep six of eight get the
tower or the water tower now it
apparently is half off man
I do not want to mess with you right now
I just eat this and then one more get
away oh no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no I just need one more man just one
more ah where are ya oh god I can't run
where's the path there's the path follow
the path just got to follow the path man
it's probably on the random tree out in
the woods somewhere
I just gotta find it I'm gonna make it
I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make it get
away
back off you [ __ ] lose them in the
trees okay where is it like a left or
rose go left
come on up this way
yes maybe this is the one gonna get it
all right
I don't know I don't know the batch oh
no no no no let that vase
no badge is a false it's a faulty come
on just keep going keep going
the path is still my friend yes hi dad
I'd say the badge I dad yes ah yes
near us
I did it I did it I put the screw in the
tuna
I put the screw in the tuna mmm yes I
did it ah hmm
I'm great ha ha ha ha ha mmm I can smell
the trees okay all right so enough of
that so I did it you can all show that I
did it I'm able to actually do this so
now I just need to get the generators
and hopefully that won't take forever
but anyway so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
won't see you in the next video
Jenna
but
Oh
Oh